one key is a travel Awards program
designed for anyone who goes anywhere
wow that's a large group use and earn
one key rewards on Expedia hotels.com
and verbo so you can earn one key cash
on a cruise and use it on an eligible
vacation home yeah you'll start saving
as soon as you join take a flight pick a
rental car stay three nights in a hotel
and get to Silver tier in a single trip
at silver gold and platinum members get
extra perks like room upgrades where
available and free breakfast oh man
that's my favorite breakfast unlock
rewards on your next trip with one key
rewards on any way you travel it's been
a while but you remember we used to
listen to voicemails from people that
would call in and we'd answer their
questions yes back in olden times yeah
well we don't have any today and that's
kind of what we're going to talk about
okay our system for collecting
voicemails has failed us what and now we
have a brand new phone number wait I
have a first of all yeah how long has
this been going on for and why wasn't I
made aware
it's been going on for a while
uh what kind of shitty organization do
we have here oh shitty one okay oh oh
there oh of the shitty ones this is the
shittiest um I'm just curious have
people been trying to leave messages and
they couldn't I believe they either
couldn't or we couldn't retrieve them
because it had something to do with us
leaving an old Network that we used to
belong to and you know company changing
companies is it possible that people
have been leaving messages out there for
us and we haven't been getting them it's
possible that's terrible in fact I'd say
it's likely that's awful I feel badly
what if people were really needing us or
needing our help the number just got
disconnected people have not been
leaving messages
that's actually good information for me
to have because it would kill me if
people were leaving us messages I have a
need to please
uh so boy I'm glad you grabbed the mic
in your Hawaiian shirt and told us well
it's time it's a little bit it's got
flowers on it and not every flowered
shirt is a Hawaiian shirt he's right now
I now you can cut this part no no no no
sorry Jerry Garcia I didn't uh
maybe it isn't a Hawaiian shirt but no
sorry just I don't mean to kill the
trouble you can get the band back
together you guys were really grooving
there for a while okay I'm glad and stop
telling us what we can cut and can't cut
we're going to leave this all in okay I
need to know what a stumble bum you are
I'm sorry anyway uh don't worry no
messages were left with that you don't
know about it just uh just the numbers
it failed a long time ago and no one
does anything about it I mean there are
messages that the listeners don't know
about because I would say one out of
every 50
000 is usable oh yeah that's a terrible
thing to say why well they're just
sometimes raving lunacy on there and I'm
I'm not even joking well wait a minute
maybe my father's in trouble
but maybe we should talk about some tips
for The Listener because we have a new
phone number oh we've got a new number
your voicemail on the podcast here are
some tips yes you can talk about we have
tips well I I could think of a few okay
yeah first of all should we read the
number and then we'll read it number if
you want to contact us or if you're a
raving lunatic that wants to scream into
the void call
669-587-2847 that number again
669-587-2847 keep it concise keep it
friendly keep it fun those are my tips
you know what I'm gonna guess I'm gonna
guess that anyone who was calling and
leaving angry and sane messages
I think your tip's probably going to
change their mind
oh oh oh Corley I'm sure
come and yell to the phone anymore about
the spaceman and the dragon in my ass
let's not call that number then I'll try
it again hello how are you
I'm an Aries I'm curious what sign you
guys are
um yeah that message will do what your
little tips will do no good I thought we
could also because sona's going to leave
the outgoing message oh I am we can just
do that right now and listeners can hear
it and then we'll take that and we'll
use it yeah let's use it uh Sona five
four three two hey you you called us and
this is this is the why are you giving
me the phone number so you can say it hi
you but they called the number to get to
the voicemail right you're just
congratulating them that they got it
right hi you called this number and you
heard a dial tone not a dial you heard
the beep and then you're leaving a
message keep it concise keep it concise
unfriendly and friendly say your name
say your name and hey you might hear
your message on the podcast and we will
get back to you as soon as we can no
we're not gonna get back to them are we
gonna get back to them this is the worst
outgoing message I've ever heard this is
I think the worst outgoing message in
the history of the world when you tell
me to do something like this it gets me
very nervous I forgot sona's personal
little Quirk is that if you give her a
task she's terrible thank you for
calling